la série hockey canada l'urss va
remporter la série canada-russie ça fait
pas l'ombre d'un guide pour moi je le
connais pas les autres sénateurs sur les
professionnels les journalistes les
avatars la série du siècle s'amorce au
forum de montréal devant le premier
ministre trudeau pierre elliott trudeau
phil esposito donné bon canada dès la
30e seconde après un deuxième bus les
représentants de l'unifolié à la 7e
minute les partisans se sont dit que
c'était dans la poche qu'elle canada
était trop fort mais les soviétiques
démontrent leur supériorité athlétique
et technique contre des canadiens vite
essoufflé loin d'être prêt à jouer au
rythme infernal de la grosse machine
rouge si
l'équipe du canada suivi de fait ce soir
je pense que nous avons un peu blessés
dans leur orgueil et vont peut-être
l'entreprise cadeau
de la rondelle
le doute est installé dans chez les
joueurs que chez les partisans à la
suite de la raclée subie à montréal une
courte victoire suivre à toronto mais
après match nul à winnipeg les joueurs
canadiens se font huer lors d'une
défaite à vancouver
ce qui soulève l'ire de phil esposito
une des grandes étoiles canadiennes
[Musique]
après une seule victoire en quatre
matches l'équipe canadienne prend le
chemin de l'europe pourrait la forme
d'abord la suède pour poursuivre sa
remise en forme et s'adapter aux
patinoires du rock international plus
grande que celle de la ligue nationale
lors du premier match à moscou phil
esposito fait une chute lors de la
présentation des joueurs et ça lui est
légalement la foule qui en fera
immédiatement en ses favoris mais le
canada aussi trébuche laisse filer une
avance de trois bus et s'inclinent 5 4
les canadiennes n'ont plus le choix ils
doivent gagner les trois matchs suivants
pour sauver leur honneur et gagner la
série le désespoir s'exprimera par de
l'intimidation et du jeu violent
notamment un coup de bâton de bois
victor qui fracasse la cheville de
meilleur joueur soviétique
valéry arramon
la tension sera à son comble lors des
trois derniers matches qui sont tous
gagnés par le canada un seul but à
chaque fois il y 3 but de la victoire
auront été marqués par le même homme par
bercy
[Applaudissements]
conspué à leur départ du canada les
hockeyeurs seront accueillis en héros à
leur retour après une victoire encore
célébrités cinquante ans plus tard
s'élever
aussi aux émotivement
ce presque impossible c'est presqu'un
point ce système en bas on oblige des
gens septembre radio-canada mourir